- [Narrator] The last video we constructed
an experiment where we
had a drug that we thought
might help control people's blood sugar.
We looked for something
that we could measure
as an indicator for their
blood sugar's being controlled,
and hemoglobin A1c is
actually what people measure
in a blood test.
It is, we have a whole
video on it on Khan Academy.
But it is an average
measure of your blood sugar
over roughly a three month period.
So that's the explanatory variable.
Whether or not you're taking the pill.
And the response variable
is well, what does it do
to your hemoglobin A1c.
And we constructed a
somewhat classic experiment
where we had a control
group and a treatment group,
and we randomly assigned
folks to either the control
or the treatment group.
And to ensure that one group of the other,
or I guess both of them, don't
end up with an imbalance of,
in the case, in the
case of the last video,
an imbalance of men or
women, we did what we call
a block design, where
we took our 100 people,
and we just happened to
have 60 women and 40 men.
We said, okay, let's split
the 60 women randomly
between the two groups,
and let's split the 40 men
between these two groups,
so that we have at least
an even distribution with respect to sex.
And we would measure folks'
A1c's before they get
the treatment or the placebo.
Then we would wait three months of getting
either the treatment or the placebo.
And then we'll see if
there is a statistically
significant improvement.
Now this was a pretty good,
and it's a bit of a classic
experimental design.
We would also do it so that
the patients don't know
which one they're getting,
placebo or the actual treatment,
so it's a blind experiment.
And it'll probably be
good if even the nurses
or the doctors who are
administering the pills
or giving the pills also don't know which
one they're getting.
So it would be a doubles blind experiment.
But this doesn't mean that
it's a perfect experiment.
There seldom is a perfect experiment,
and that's why it should
be able to be replicated,
that other people should
try to prove the same thing.
It may be in different ways,
But even the way that we designed it,
There's still a possibility
that there's some
lurking variables in here.
Maybe we took care to
make sure our distribution
of men and women was roughly even
across both of these groups,
but maybe my throwing
at random sampling, we got
a disproportionate number
of young people and the treatment group.
And maybe young people responded
better to taking a pill.
Maybe that changes their
behaviors in other ways.
But maybe older people,
when they take a pill,
they decide to eat worse
because they say the pills
are gonna solve all my problems.
And so you can have these
other lurking variables
like age, or where in
the country the live,
or other types of things, that
just by the random process
you might have things get uneven
one way or another.
Now one technique
To help control for this a little bit.
And I shouldn't use controlled too much.
Another technique to help mitigate this,
is something called matched pairs design.
Matched, matched pairs.
Pairs design of an experiment,
and it's essentially
instead of going through
all this trouble saying,
oh boy maybe we do block design
or all this random sampling.
Instead, you randomly put
people first into either
the control or the treatment group,
and then we do another round you measure,
and then you do another
round where you switch,
where the people who are in the treatment
go to the control, and the
people who are in the control
go into the treatment.
So we can even extend
from what we have here.
We can imagine a a world
where the first three months
we have the 50 people
in this treatment group,
we have another 50 people
in this control group,
they are taking the placebo.
We see what happens to the
A1Cs, and then we switch.
Where this group over here.
Then, they don't know, they don't know.
First of all, ideally
it's a blind experiment
so they don't even know
they're on the treatment group,
so hopefully the pills look identical.
So now that same group
for the next three months
is now going to be the control group.
And so they got the medicine
for the first there months
and we saw what happens to their A1c,
and now we're gonna pet the placebo,
then we're going to get the placebo
for the second three months,
And then we're going to
see what happens to their
A1c and likewise the
other group is going to be
switched around.
The thing that the folks
that used to be getting
the placebo could now get the treatment.
They are now going to get the treatment.
And the value here is,
is that because everyone
is going through, is it for one period
in the control group, and once period
is in the treatment group.
But they don't know
when, which one happening
you are less likely to
have a lurking variable
like age or geographic region
or behavior, cause an imbalance
or in somehow skew the results
of give you a biased result.
So this is an interesting thing,
even when I've talked
about it in this video
in the last one, these aren't just
different ways to approach it,
and as you construct experiments,
this is in medicine.
You'll obviously construct experiments
in other fields.
It's important to think
about what types of things
are practical to do.
And also (stammering) have the best chance
at giving you real, I guess you could say,
an unbiased and real information
as to in the case of an experiment
to the efficacy of something,
or whether a certain variable,
an explanatory variable really does drive,
have a causal effect
on a response variable.